what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today with the
spider-man no way home official trailer
finally out let's keep the journey going
with something that you know we have
been doing all along spider-man no way
home real plot leak proven
by teaser trailer excited to see what's
in store excited to see what warren was
indeed right about all this time but
guys before we go into that got a shout
out today's sponsor and that is
squarespace not sure if you've ever
heard of squarespace from any youtuber
before we might be the first ones ever
to tell you about squarespace but hey i
came up with this myself if you're
looking to build your own perfect
website stick around till the end of the
video to find out more let's roll into
this
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
i'm still coming down from the
spider-man no way home teaser trailer
hype
hello peter
[Music]
but let's be honest i think it's going
to be a while until most of us come down
from it and if you haven't heard the
spider-man no way home teaser trailer
broke the record for most online views
in its first 24 hours after release
which is what insane but not unexpected
it got
355.5 million views worldwide top of the
total of 289 million views avengers game
for avengers and no way what i actually
did not hear about that i have not been
around social media since they were
filming this that's exciting that makes
perfect sense actually you know knowing
the amount of build up that we have had
towards this one trailer there was a lot
of anticipation and demand for the end
game trailer believe me i remember that
time but i don't think it quite reached
the level of spider-man no way home
weirdly enough so that's just kind of
awesome to learn that effect right here
with that camera pointed at us new
trailer to beat that is awesome that's
so exciting well earned well deserved
even with a leak the day before that's
amazing and this is just the teaser can
you imagine if they actually put all
three spider-man on screen in a trailer
for a significant amount of time i think
that would easily beat this teaser
i must issue however a spoiler warning i
am about to talk about the actual plot
for spider-man no way home there are
let's go
if you've been following me and my
spider-man videos you know that a lot of
the leaks that i've been talking about
are true they were confirmed true by the
teaser trailer the same thing goes for
these plot details that i'm going to be
revisiting and breaking down right now
so you have been warned i think a good
majority of you have probably heard this
one before so i'm just going to read
through it and then we'll talk about it
and connect it to the trailer afterwards
sure it says peter's life is ruined
after his identity was revealed at the
end of the last mysterio movie accurate
he is now facing trial matt murdock is
his lawyer peter goes to doctor strange
and asks him to cast a spell to make
everyone forget that he is spider-man
however something goes wrong with the
spell and they break reality and bring
five spider villains of other dimensions
to the mcu
i'm the first spider-man film doc from
spider-man 2 to confirm man from the
third spider-man film the list we think
we saw
electro from the amazing spider-man 2.
we know his work aka the green goblin is
talking to the others asking what is the
last thing they remember and they all
say spider-man killed them doctor
strange wants to take them back to their
original dimensions but the villains
fear that returning would mean that they
would return exactly where they came
from meaning they would die again peter
wants to let them free because he feels
bad because the other spider-man in the
other universes killed them okay so so
far what we definitely have confirmed
the events of far from home picking up
right from there him going to dr strange
a lot of us i've already sold ourselves
ourselves included
that's matt murdock in the trailer from
the neck down the hairy arms looks so
like this looks so much like him and we
got some of the villains in here but we
don't know exactly how they all break
out there's a lot of like missing detail
points there so we'll see we'll see
sometimes these are conflicting
sometimes these are accurate but the
journey is still just beginning peter
fights doctor strange and breaks the key
which is a cube that held them captive
and the villains are now free if you
caught my breakdown you can remember
that i mentioned the cuban that it was
very important i didn't remember exactly
what it was at the time but now i do
thanks to this plot leak it is the key
that keeps them in the prison but peter
breaks it the villains are now free and
they start destroying parts of new york
and to stop them peter somehow brings
toby maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man to the mcu to help him there
is a big rematch between toby maguire
spider-man and doc awk and between
andrew garfield spider-man and electro
the final battle is at the statue of
liberty with the three spider-man
fighting together fighting the sinister
six
is crazy about watching this it's like
we've seen so many different videos like
beyond just warning about spider-man no
i hope i didn't know we actually have
real footage to compliment everything
that's being talked about it's just such
a weird journey it doesn't feel real
still
it feels like some hypothetical fanfic
it's like oh it's like real footage is
crazy to be clear i have no idea who the
sixth member is or when or how they come
into the scene mysterious scorpions the
senate the sixth one and the villain
that we were questioning if it was
lizard or not i believe it now is
because of this plot leak because keep
in mind i was that looks like a lizard
three weeks ago maybe a month ago i did
a video on it we can go back and find
that video but it was way before the
teaser trailer and everything in it is
accurate which also means for some
doubters out there which i totally
understand but it also means that toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man are indeed they're definitely
in this now this actually does help
clear up a few things in the teaser
trailer there is one specific scene
where we see dr strange and peter on a
train dr strange is performing some
crazy cool magic and a lot of people
were wondering if they're fighting here
and now the answer looks like yes but
the other question was who are they
fighting and the answer is they're
fighting each other and to me it's kind
of funny because it's like sorry peter
but you stand no chance against doctor
strange and we can see that in this
footage doctor strange takes the train
that they're on and duplicates it and
sends them off into the sky he's the
master of the mystic arts sorry peter
you don't really have a chance here but
of course they're going to be allies i
don't believe that they're going to
actually be enemies throughout the movie
this will probably be a pretty epic
fight and then after doctor strange is
going to say something like well we have
to get them back if you didn't catch our
live stream one thing that we were
really theorizing because a lot of
people were asking about dr strange's
behavior like that was a five and a half
hour live stream and at least half the
questions were all about doctor strange
and what we think might be going on with
him and for me it's like some people are
saying the whole mephisto thing some are
like maybe it's one to control him i and
i'm like i'm more likely to be mephisto
than i am thinking it has something to
do with wanda however i wouldn't be
surprised if after the whole ordeal of
you know trying to erase everyone's mind
from peter parker if actually we we saw
two different doctor stranges in
this trailer alone and maybe he's
fighting that version of doctor strange
could just be another fun fight scene
between you know like hey when the
heroes fight each other it might be most
likely however i don't know maybe after
everything happens and you got this
multiverse stuff happening you got a
darker doctor strange maybe the one from
what if comes in how crazy would that be
right right right right now another
thing this confirms is that matt murdock
aka daredevil is going to be peter's
lawyer in the beginning in my breakdown
i put a few photos of this mysterious
person and it really really does look
like matt murdock and since this leak
has been pretty accurate so far i'm
going to go ahead and say yes that is
him i absolutely believe it confirmed
something that alfred molina said in a
recent interview about returning as doc
ock yes he did give it away he straight
up just told everybody yeah i'm
returning for spider-man no way home he
even said that he had a conversation
with the director about how he was going
to return when he was dead which the
director replied in this universe no
one's really dead and obviously with the
multiverse that's true and he said that
he was going to be taken from that
moment at the very end when he is
sinking into the water which means he's
going to be taken right before he dies
and we can assume that this is going to
be true for the other villains as well
this is confirmed when norman osborne
asks everybody what's the last thing you
remember and they all say spider-man
killing them except for the sandman
because he did not die which is actually
why i believe and some other people do
as well that he's going to be good in
the truth
with the lightning and that could be him
actually trying to protect peter parker
at the end of spiderman
i forgive you and sandman was just
trying to do it for his daughter but
wait a minute that wouldn't make him a
sixth member of the sinister or one of
the six you know if he's actually a good
guy or maybe there's some level of
conflict that does arise later on maybe
starts off as the thomas hayden church
who is like you know on a better path
right now and then goes back to having
to join sides with the sinisters yeah
maybe he's got nothing to lose after
being plucked into this dimension or he
has to or maybe the only way to get back
home is do the the mission with the
sinister you know this says that the
final battle is going to take place on
the statue of liberty and it's going to
be the three spider-man versus the
sinister six and we've actually seen a
leaked photo of the statue of liberty
holding a captain america shield and
this was from the set of spider-man no
way home so we can also believe that
that is indeed going to be the final
scene and the last thing i want to talk
about is something that is very key pun
intended to spiderman no way home which
is the cube key that doctor strange has
that peter breaks i've heard a little
bit of rumblings around about what this
key actually does and it's pretty much
like it says it keeps the villains
trapped inside of some sort of magical
prison the only thing i'm really unclear
of right now is whether or not the
villains kind of just pop out of the
middle of the air then doctor strange
goes and he retrieves them and he puts
them in the prison or if they pop up in
the sanctum somehow that's kind of a
part that i'm unclear of but i would
really love to see doctor strange fight
these villains i also heard that doctor
strange somehow gets hurt and he needs
his power to kind of rebuild the key or
keep it together because that's how
they're going to get them back to them
you got to get him out of the movie for
a while right
peter parker which is why the other
peter parker's come in yeah exactly you
know like if doctor strange was here
you'd be like why isn't he just why is
this his movie
a few waves of his hands yeah you got to
get rid of him at some point or else the
stakes are greatly diminished if you
have doctor strange fighting with you
the whole time but that's why i was
saying that maybe something goes wrong
and there might be an evil doctor
strange in here but then it would become
about bursting that evil doctor strange
but then again
that might be an indicator that the
fight between doctor strange and peter
parker instead of them going all right
we need to work together on this maybe
spider-man wins that fight somehow and
then dr strange gets injured so it's
just this big sequence of consequences
that peter has to deal with i don't know
how maybe he uses wong for help i don't
know long leaves in the trailer maybe
comes back but we'll see we'll see and i
know a lot of people were saying well we
really want our spider-man tom hall and
spider-man to kind of go into his own
character not really get help and i do
think we are going to see that in this
film i do think at some point doctor
strange will kind of be taken out of the
picture and it's really just going to be
about him and it's going to be his
decision to bring the other spider-man
in and it's going to be his decision on
what to do with the villains i do think
he's really going to grow up here but so
far that i know that is the most
accurate plot details that we have again
i got it way before the trailer came out
and when the trailer came out it proved
most of it real so be sure to let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below and if you're new
consider subscribing to the channel to
stay up to date on spider-man news and
of course mcu news for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
all right awesome let the journey
continue on until the movie finally
comes out thanks warren for putting that
together and thank you for keeping us
accompanied with spider-man info
throughout this whole journey leading up
to the trailer and now we have like at
least one more
perhaps preferably two more guys
subscribe to cosmic wonder subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button thank you so
much for being here
and of course big thanks to squarespace
for sponsoring today's video because
guys if you're looking to build yourself
the perfect website definitely check out
the tools and resources available
through squarespace maybe you need
publishing tools to help you organize
and schedule some blog posts i do or you
want to take your engagement to the next
level well then you want to take
advantage of this fully integrated
comment like and response system i like
that very much then
this is for you you're going to want to
use the code either way squarespace has
a beautiful online platform beautiful
and it's here to help you connect
it's here to help you connect with your
audience and even generate revenue via
gated members only content i like
revenue you can manage your members send
emails communications and leverage your
audience insights i like communicating
all in one easy to use platform easy so
you can integrate your website with your
social media they can do it all and with
squarespace extensions they can even
help with things like inventory
management bookkeeping shipping and more
i'm really appealed to the more part so
much more in fact you can even get a
free trial of squarespace free at
squarespace.com squarespace.com and when
you're ready to launch head to
squarespace.com
the real rejects save 10
on your first purchase of a domain or a
new website you hear that yeah so once
again thank you squarespace for
sponsoring the squarespace rejects
that's our new name that's right
be there be square but don't reject
squarespace space out space
[Music]